[Musique]
via la solidarité est du type ii italia
comment se fait-il comment je me sens quand ici à
vole une aiguille émotionnelle pirate du
médecine de guana au monde et à la personne qui
beaucoup le besoin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les chercheurs des professeurs arrivent
faculté de médecine qui ont été dans
première ligne dès le premier instant
dans l'épicentre et il est donc important
l'échange d'expériences avec les nôtres
chercheurs de première ligne dans le
combattre le coronavirus donc aussi
c'est une attention à ceux qui
rechercher l'activité pour obtenir le
dès que possible pour vaincre cela
costume rouge si agressif
[Musique]